he's Mike Tirico the popular host of NBC
Sports Mike good morning how are you I'm
good I didn't hear you earlier I'm sorry
I thought I thought the show last night
was actually really good yeah I thought
that it had its moments
but do you remember do you have a
favorite SP moment oh well the V moment
obviously because we were at the point
Chris Myers and i anchored SportsCenter
after that you and the rest of the VIPs
were weren't you there yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah so we're always told look this is a
very important show right after the
ESPYs that's why we have you guys angry
sorry
wait you're not weren't you like the two
guys the two Muppets who were up in the
balcony that was you and Chris Myers uh
no I I don't think I did that either I
went to a few of them after it and then
honestly I've watched the SBS at the
British Open for most of the last 15 20
years because it's that same week so I I
haven't been in the States this is the
first one I've seen live in a while but
Peyton was great but you're right about
the old days it was hard to get no
athletes to come so if you saw them you
had a good idea they were going to win
however I think it's very genuine that
the athletes are happy to be there and
this generation has grown up with the
ESPYs meaning something so good to the
people at our old place who invested the
time in it because last night I was
thoroughly entertained by the show and
Peyton was as we shouldn't be surprised
he was unbelievable you're so good do
you think Kevin Durant was acting when
Peyton man you okay would you play the
Peyton Manning joke involving Kevin
Durant then they had a cutaway to Kevin
Durant and then Russell Westbrook
gymnastics team was so dominant that
Kevin Durant told me he wants to play
for them next year
and I gotta tell you I don't think you'd
start for that team Kevin yeah love the
rest but what do you think
that was great I was great and I thought
I really really thought that Durant was
in on the joke all I do to every but
everybody didn't think I was shocked I
thought I was being maybe I'm the ones
dumb and being duped but then when
Durant got up on stage a couple of times
he was serious no business no play
playing the role of not the happiest cat
in the room so maybe I was wrong I don't
know I thought that they were both in on
it yes
Westbrook looked like he was dying too
laughing but Durant just want a title
it's not like he lost and then they made
the joke about it he won the title
he should be smiling at everything that
they had last night and it's the ESPYs
you hit though what you said a moment
ago the line of the night was Edelman
that's fabulous yes about Payton yeah
indoors it was great all right I have
this idea with the economic Reger Floyd
Mayweather fight and McGregor and
Mayweather addressed it yesterday but
sequent you play that for Mike Tirico
here's Floyd Mayweather with my idea the
bag up and we will say what the books
look like and do believe in yourself
touching things believe in yourself
[ __ ] go home fight
no problem Stan the contract is done
okay how about winner-take-all and
doesn't make that the biggest spectacle
in sports history that 200 million
dollars could be at stake what do you
think if let's say you're MacGregor and
you lose mayweather is at the point
where he's okay and obviously McGregor's
made a significant amount of money if
you're McGregor and you take that and
you lose
do you really limit future earnings I
think he's going to be I think he's
going to do well because of how he's
promoted himself in this tour that that
he showed himself he'll certainly do
well on Showtime another pay cable yes
you can continue this where he can
continue this language you're right
about Bill you know you're not going to
get this fight again a fight of this
magnitude but wouldn't that make it too
big if you're Dana White and you somehow
you go to them and say guys people are
going to keep asking about this you guys
are talking tough why don't we just put
up or shut up but all the money in the
middle everybody's all in it's the World
Series of Poker let's go let's plug well
would it would it increase the intrigue
absolutely I think I think this tour was
brilliant because they're hitting the
right places hitting three countries in
four days all that stuff and they are
really creating interest with the unique
part of it too there the boxing was
great when the personalities match the
quality in the ring we haven't had the
combination of personalities and quality
in a while
McGregor does within a sport so you add
the intrigue with the big build up here
and maybe they will get a mega event I'm
so surprised that they're doing at the
end of August I don't understand and I
don't know this game well enough I don't
understand why you don't do this later
on in the year usually there's always a
big pay-per-view fight in November you
know late in the fall and it's football
season and people are around the last
big weekend of summer there before Labor
Day I just think you're taking people
away from home and you can't maximize
your audience I don't know those guys
are smarter than me yeah I didn't
if you wanted to stay away from the
football season or the fact you got
ahead of the triple G Canelo Alvarez
fight yeah but I don't look Dana white
as as made as of billions or millions by
being a great marketer so I'm sure they
have some strategy by the way the
official announcement for Mike Tirico
the introduction tune in this Saturday
the launch of the Olympic channel home
of Team USA brand new 24/7 home of the
Olympics allowing fans to connect with
Olympics the Olympic sports athletes and
stories all year round still waiting on
official confirmation here of Los
Angeles or Paris for the 2024 games what
do you think the hold up is in how do
you decide between Paris and Los Angeles
well it looks like the IOC from
everything they said this week wants to
award will award both at once and the
question is can they negotiate
comfortably between the two cities so
one gets one for 24 and the other will
get 28 obviously they both want to go in
24 do you want to be on the clock for 11
years waiting to host an Olympic Games
needless to say that will be the most
planned out Olympic Games of all time
but but they'd like to do both
announcements at once both cities seem
to be playing nice and those
conversations are ongoing whether it is
24 or 28 it will be great
assuming everything stays in place to
have the Olympics back in the US and to
have it in in Los Angeles again so all
the things seem to be pointed in the
right direction I think a lot of folks
and the Paris I'd want to see the
hundredth anniversary so they host in
2024 and for everyone in LA obviously
you don't want to be there waiting 11
years but they're trying to settle it
and figure it out and then I think
you're going to see some reform in the
selection process for Olympic cities
because they'll have it planned out to
2028 and they can really get about some
significant reforms in this process for
hosting the games and I would love to
see where you could get a couple of
cities that rotate the Winter Games in a
couple of cities that rotate the Summer
Games because we're looking what happens
the fall out when the Olympics pull out
and move on you know these some of these
cities are just devastated
I wonder if real ever recovers from this
in Greece every
from this whereas you could have it in
the Pacific Northwest let's say you had
Seattle as your central location and you
use Portland and you use San Francisco
and San Jose make it more of a sweeping
a couple of states involved in it if you
wanted to do Los Angeles and you wanted
to do San Diego that's where I think we
should be headed instead of saying we're
going to put the onus on you know Ken
Chicago or Boston hostess you almost
have to make it a little bit more of a
bigger community and that might be part
of the reform down the line that's why
they want to award these games and I do
agree with the concept in the principle
of the Olympic Games are there to try to
enhance a city and the legacy has not
been enhancement of those cities in
every regard since so hopefully they can
figure out a way to do that but clearly
a big establish city like a Paris like a
Los Angeles less likely to be
significantly set back now has the
Olympic Games significantly set back
real which too early to say that but
there are things that you hoped would be
coming from the games that have it and
we knew that when we were there too you
were there we we could see that so you
know this is you think back to the games
Barcelona had very good games in 92
you're going to love this thing on the
Olympic Channel Dan we're going to go
back and show every game that the dream
team played its 25th anniversary there's
a documentary with it that some of the
stuff the Olympic channel can do go back
and reshow this stuff because I was
thinking about it I don't remember
sitting and watching a dream team game
other than during the 92 competition and
now for kids who only heard about the
dream team it gets to go back and watch
them play some of these games which will
be fun to see Jordan to see Berkeley to
see those guys actually playing with
this best basketball team ever tune in
this Saturday the launch of the Olympic
Channel home of Team USA it's a new 24/7
home of the Olympics a speaking of just
watching it was fun to just watch Lonzo
ball play there was nothing to do with
his family there was like everything the
Seas parted and he just walked in a
played basketball it was fun to watch
and you got to see something that if
you're a Laker fan there's there's a lot
of promise
there and it's going to be a lot of fun
I don't know if there going to be any
good anytime soon but it was really fun
to just watch him play last night
mostl Brown doing our last night you
know what's weird maybe it was his
excuse to not go to the ESPYs but he I'm
watching Lanza where is Kobe Bryant 90s
okay now I I have a theory here it
almost feels like we're saying to Nike
hey can we want to be in the family here
I love to have LeBrons blessing here
would you buy big baller brand here I
don't know why else you would be wearing
Kobe's shoes when you're trying to sell
big baller brand it's such an
interesting sub has taken away from what
you talked about I I watched these
summer league games I'll put them on
casually and watch them and not get too
involved because you fall in love with
guys you remember they're you're not
planning they're playing against the
guys they just played against for the
most part you get some guys with the
year of NBA experience this is not the
defense or anything else they're going
to see when they get there what you just
want to see if guys really have what it
takes and it looks like the early part
of this draft lottery group has it yeah
and for Lonzo ball there are going to be
bad nights like there were in the summer
league and then they're going to be
nights where he plays really well you
would hope that the quality like he said
the quality of play on the floor becomes
the thing we talked about and not the
other four or five things however the
NBA has brilliantly found a way to do
what football does and that's stay in
the conversation year-round
dat's what baseball used to do how many
times did we always talk as kids about
the hot stove league that doesn't happen
anymore but now football it's year-round
and basketball the conversations been
better than the competition to be candid
safe travels to the British Open there
when you leave it
I leave this weekend again on the ground
Sunday and one week from right now will
be about ten hours into our first day of
coverage can't wait
Thank You bud see you bud alright that's
Mike Tirico
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience